devine I have to ask you you and Luca
your characters hook up this season of
the show when you saw that in the script
were you okay with it yeah because I
mean it would be a complicated thing you
know I know that this is something it
yeah actors have to write and it was my
first time doing that on television
right so I was like so this is gonna be
like tutors like I'm gonna take all my
clothes off like in my mind it was way
more intense what it was he was such a
sweetie about it he was like no it's TBS
I was like no but like what are they
gonna show like what can we cover up I
need makeup body makeup I know
everything
this is this is exactly how he acted on
my wedding night yeah to be fair we did
take all our clothes t vs demands out of
everything we do here naked in our Andy
and I are naked in our rehearsals now
Nancy you had a moment where you were
reading your script and you realize that
your character is part of a swinging
threesome was not something that you
were okay with well I Margaret just got
over her head a little bit she's just
got two boyfriends that's so she's not
really a swinger she just that's with
that soul about that's not how I
interpret it I interpreted is your
character's you know off the hook off
the chain everything that kids that's
what the kids say these days it's early
90s second base
you